you
design is a compact yet multifaceted
representation of Singapore the
exhibition simplicity and clarity
asserts the power of architecture and
designed to communicate important ideas
about the world we live in
the success of the exhibition as
evidenced by this award is really the
product of collaboration being open to
everyone's ideas well at the same time
ensuring that the exhibition is clear
direct and focused
Singapore is a place that needs to be
discovered over time many facets that
may appear obvious even bernal in
Singapore can suddenly become
fascinating if one takes a closer look
Singapore is full of places things and
ideas many of which are hidden requiring
exploration curiosity and thinking to
understand the world one must understand
home
you